we're diving in digging in are you guys
hungry
and doing it all in Singapore I'm done
it's time for roses and Rose Bay guys I
know I know I know but this doesn't
affect this okay I love you all so much
thank you for your support and I thank
you I know anyway i'm lauren zima and we
are here to recap episode 4 of colton
underwood season of The Bachelor guys
this episode felt so real and grounded
and deep and emotional a lot of reveals
a lot of weird foods I feel like we're
getting to the place now where that
relationships are on another level
do you agree what do you think are you
sensing true connections at this point
it's getting really easy to see which
women are far ahead in which women are
falling far behind right right right is
that just me okay so first of all Chris
Harrison calls Hannah yeah that was a
view tailing kill that was a view I
think feel like I don't know that but I
feel like he did that on purpose
well my name's Hannah oh I'm sorry yeah
that's my guess but it was kind of
wonderful and then this was so awkward
right there are things said about me
that should have never been said about
me Hannah just starts talking to the
whole group about how bad stuff was said
about her and she's talking about Kaelyn
like she's not there and just addressing
the whole awkward elephant in the room
that is in fact like the room it's not
just an elephant in the room it's the
whole room is this energy it was so
weird but refreshing because I'm not
sure that anyone really just says it in
front of everybody like that usually
it's like this conversation in this one
at this time it was everybody and then
it's time to take this thing to the next
level I thought that Chris Harrison was
about to mess with everybody because
he's like we're going to an amazing
place we got to get out of here never
been before on the show in the history
of this show a magical land far off dr.
bad fantastic fantabulous and I thought
he's about to be like you'll be meeting
Colton Branson Missouri but instead
Singapore Singapore Wow we leave in an
hour go could you pack in an hour I
actually can't have a quick Packer and I
always carry on I don't check bags I
don't have time for that what your bag
gets lost traveling too much to deal
with that I carried on for two weeks in
Europe did my clothes smell yes it
didn't affect my sight see anyway so we
are in Singapore and Colton says of
Singapore that it has quotes it's got
the lights the building's the lights and
the buildings anyway
Taoiseach let's fall in love cold
Taoiseach gets a one-on-one date which I
did not see coming I'm not sure that I
knew Colton I had that connection to
Taoiseach maybe there's some footage on
the cutting room floor that we didn't
see but I would have seen him giving
other women a one-on-one before her
that being said she seems lovely it's
frustrating
I know what happens on those one-on-ones
I know they're probably gonna have a
good time what does that mean Anna yes
well we all know what happens on those
one-on-ones and what happened on your
one on one was actually the outlier kind
of a disaster when you tried to make
that toast so I'm not sure you do know
what happens what's we get another
selfie video from Colton and why why why
do we stop doing that we don't need it
why I just let him have that
confessional that as they call it i TM I
don't need the iPhone footage it's all
chopped up okay so about to film roses
and Rose a and address everything I
don't really know how it's gonna go but
yeah it's gonna be there's gonna be fun
and what are they gonna do they are
going to bungee jump would you do it
would you do it would you do it if
somebody wanted to do it would you do it
would you do it it was so high up you
guys I was actually freaked out by that
like I mean because the thing is you're
not even like climbing and you're just
falling you're just free-falling you're
not even being lowered slowly you are
lowering yourself let me know if you
would have done it another great quote
tisha said falling and loved
I won't come down that which on the one
hand is an incredibly vague duh thing to
say but on the other hand kind of a
funny pun she said I'm down with that
get it
what are them more than what meets the
eye with that taste chef
I love how Taoiseach said to Colton
right before he jumped you could hear
him kind of under his breath go yeah
she's like talking himself up like him
good fun fun fun fun fun fun so they
jump off that platform and then we get
some great shots of them getting into
their swimwear very sexy love tee shows
red one-piece I love a one-piece what do
you guys think you prefer a one-piece or
a bikini moment I'm all about the
one-piece as long as you can make sure
that it fits you in the right place is
right and that you don't get any weird
moments I'm talking about you don't want
it hug in the wrong places in the wrong
ways I was married and I got divorce and
then taste reveals that she got divorced
and you know what good for you girl
cause she owned it talked about it and
now she's moving on with her life on The
Bachelor all right all right I was
surprised to hear that cold sake I have
divorced parents I'm not sure I knew
that did we know that I liked the dinner
overall I felt like they had good
conversation I liked Colton's insight
onto not judging other people's
happiness what do you think of Colton
tatius connections I'm here for it you
know what I haven't been drinking enough
yet that feels better
hydrating Sokka hydrating it's fine I
know I was a little nervous to do this
video for you guys all minute I just
feel that you're now here with me and
I'm glad you're here with me anyway you
got the wild one
so then Kalin gets a one-on-one and a
Hanabi is drinking in her confessional
so let's drink to Hana be drinking in
her confessional I get it girl
you need a good girl I feel young that I
don't know you can't know much about you
at all but it is frustrating to see even
more time to go into this whole
situation and then we had another moment
where someone called out another woman
in front of everyone
Demi just slay his Kalin just says she
doesn't deserve this one-on-one because
Cole has already been so focused on the
Kaelyn Hanabi drama dang that was cold
icy and free sing I need my Rose blanket
actually can't anybody hear it thank you
thanks Jane your opinions their opinion
I'm over it I don't respect you anymore
I've moved on so uh and can't what did
you guys think of the way Kailyn handled
it she kind of shut dummy down honestly
I exceed the pageant experience with
Kailyn she knows how to just maintain
and eschew and say goodbye to you
Demi I don't really do the in-your-face
type physicality because I don't know
now we've got the group date we get
group dates like this every once in a
while we're you know like sometimes we
have a game with really confusing
parameters and sometimes honestly were
just hanging out and exploring and
that's what they were doing in Singapore
the group date was just a group of
people walking off the street like that
was the group date you are the child of
the Quinta yes she is a spring in summer
she is your sister she's my sister
bleach lady I think we should go check
this out so they're walking around in
Singapore but then we do get a little
bit of a moment because they're going to
be bleached I don't know what the right
verb is there to be leached leach
whatever leeches were stuck on them and
Cortney asked is this even up to code
like where did they get these leeches
from are they FDA approved they have the
answer is no I and I also know the FDA
isn't in Singapore so
no but are these leeches actually
sucking their blood out I mean that is
what I know elite to do like when
they've got these leeches on them I
think that they're drawing blood from
them beliefs follow me
do you guys know anything about leeches
and I'm missing something and what are
these leeches really giving any actual
health benefits I don't know I was
really questioning it and then they go
to eat some food are you guys hungry
yeah and we are eating and eel oh wow
wow wow
would you guys try this stuff honestly I
would I'll eat most things except hey
Tong weirds me out when people eat
tongue just cuz of I think about the
texture like when I back summer invite
my own tongue really so he Anna eats a
fish I and I loved her for doing this I
felt like we saw the fun playful Hannah
again I love her for saying bye George
I love her this girl thought the fumbled
was a word but then she knows like the
old-timey phrase bye George
who's Hannah what more to learn about
Hannah then we get more good moments
from Hannah her and Colton have a nice
little chat after the Singapore
excursion and this discussion goes well
they work some stuff out they talk some
stuff out her earrings are swinging in
the air just as the tide is turning for
Hannah and Colton though isn't it those
earrings really dangling around I wanted
to reach out and study them
[Music]
maintain because I like to send my eyes
nothing I couldn't tell okay then a
Cassie and Colton have a moment
I like how Colton isn't a see the word
that I latched on to he said brother and
sister in a past life okay yeah he
actually becomes like playful and funny
and makes jokes with her I feel like we
Leeds talked a lot about how they want
their goofy side to come out finally
when they're the lead because as a
contestant you don't really get to show
your funny side it's more about drama I
feel like in that level with cassia
really for the first time saw quilting
the sense of humor and I liked seeing it
I like them together it seemed natural
[Music]
damn you in there that's not a kiss than
a sister would give and then we get to
Demi and Courtney we have had Demi and
Tracy well I can't imagine like if I
were an older girl we have had Hannah
and Kaylin there's a beautiful monster
inside of me but Demi and Courtney might
be the most insane argument thus far
this season you guys Courtney I really
just think that you need to
get out of your own head and here's the
thing who do you side with I side with
Demi I do
Courtney is sitting there and she's like
I have been waiting patiently and being
respectful to all the other girls
no girl learn the ropes you should not
sit there quietly go talk to him and
Demi argued that she was trying to
encourage Courtney and she was she was
like you can't make excuses you just
have to act you got to get out there you
got to talk to him Demi was like her
coach and Courtney was a player and she
was a you got to get out there and you
got to make the place and you got to
throw the ball and you gotta kick the
ball you gotta pass the ball and you got
to get it to other people out on the
field other sport with your team and I
should have started with this analogy
this was a rough way to go for me Demi
was like Bradley Cooper and Courtney was
like Lady gaga and Bradley was like look
I know this is your first movie but I'm
here for you there might be a hundred
people in the room but all you need is
one person to believe in you and that
person is me so you are gonna get out
there and you are gonna be Ally and
sometimes we're gonna go off script but
you know what it's gonna feel natural
it's gonna feel good and I've got your
back and we are gonna kill it and get
nominated all awards season long
that's what I should have gone with okay
that felt better so in the midst of the
Demi Courtney fight Demi talks to Colton
and drops that bomb about her mom being
in federal prison whatever sure Demi is
honestly going through the pages of
exactly what a standout contestant on
The Bachelor should do she's caused some
drama she's been herself she's been sexy
and now she's getting deep and emotional
Debbie's kind of nailing it guys like
Demi is progressing with each episode
just like the progression of the entire
storyline of the show and we're watching
debbie unfold and I like it
people are already having double time so
you should get up double time yeah so go
go just go up there I then but got
borderline offended because Courtney was
all upset the Demi got a second chat
with Colton when Courtney literally had
not gotten up off her chair seemingly to
go talk to him there's so much why don't
you understand I was open about being
upset about not having time and then she
had the nerve to accuse Debbie of trying
to play God
deciding what you need to say was one
where she wasn't trying to play God she
was trying to play Bradley Cooper and
direct you to the Oscar Courtney gaga
but you didn't want to get there you
didn't want to be directed it's your
first time in a film and you didn't want
the Pro behind you you made the mistake
here that's what I think um also when
Courtney asked dummy how old she was
stop you guys are the same age Courtney
you're the same age I'm so tired of
people criticizing Tammy for her age
stuff yourselves especially when you are
her age stop yourself
Courtney is crying is that she could go
home and I wrote down honestly Courtney
DB [ __ ] well you know what happens
during the rest of this episode guys
still have been drinking enough it's
like I'm I'm a little bit nervous so I'm
not drinking that doesn't make sense
oh my I've been waiting for this special
day for so long maybe downstairs Coulson
next up Kalyan goes on our one-on-one
Hannah's mad that Galen gets a
one-on-one but girl as a reminder you
already had one
Hannah then points up ya know that
revealed she was there showing up at
Miss USA in hide a plan I should have
clapped for her when she walked out for
helping a woman shake again cold I see I
need my blanket again I'm so cold
I couldn't think of anybody more
deserving than you so : keep saying he
wants to spoil Kailyn I don't really
know why but my favorite part of all
this is that Hannah B is talking to
Hannah G and says in all seriousness
when you pass her she's an interest what
if he gets her genes in a cute top
what if he gets her an adorable matching
sweat suit what if he gets her some
great PJ's I don't know secrets of
address matter what are you guys are
getting diamond necklace it was just
funny to me Wow but my favorite part of
this shopping date is that guy off to
the side who he was providing commentary
at one point he said Jennifer Lopez EJ
he was great
let's get that guy out of every single
date in the Singapore so Caitlyn comes
back with all these shopping bags it's
really a pretty woman moment and I was
shocked by how she reacted to this we
cut to Cassie in tears she says it's so
hard to watch a guy she's dating do this
for another woman and this kind of made
me question Cassie's ability to like
maintain in this competition that just
felt out of nowhere to me I thought a
Hannah was gonna have a strong reaction
man Cassie breaking down in tears I
don't know she's been calm and collected
up until this point but Cassie might
have a breakdown
so then we come to a point in the show
where Caitlin it makes this big reveal
to Colton and talks about her sexual
assault this is a big conversation that
I have to have it's a part of who I am
it's a part of my story it's um it's
like not an easy thing for me to talk
about and I just want to applaud the
show for the way that they handled it I
thought that Kalyan really was able to
tell her story in her own words which
was great
and I want to applaud Colton for the way
that he just took in what she was saying
how supportive he was of her I just
truly thought that the whole moment was
handled well and it was an incredibly
emotional story to watch and so many
women have had these experiences it's
been it's been hard but like it shaped
me as a person and it's made me so
strong and like made me the person that
I am today
and I and I like to be happy and goofy
and fun but it's like it's like a dark
part of my history but I'm not gonna let
that like diminish me or Who I am
Thank You Kailyn for sharing your story
that's all I can say I thought it was
powerful and I really appreciated it I
think the thing I realize is everybody
who asked me it's like why are you a
virgin
they expect this simple answer yeah we
also hear a little bit more from Colton
with him explaining more behind his
reason for being a virgin and I think
Colton for sharing that too and it makes
a lot of sense I understand it so I was
just really grateful that the show gave
us this moment of relatability shining a
spotlight on an issue that needs to be
talked about and I'm glad that we had it
but let me know what you guys think was
there anything that you would have liked
handled or explained or dealt with
differently let me know because it's
important to have the discussions then
we're back to the Singapore hotel
mansion situation Hanna and Kaylin talk
things out and it wasn't like the most
perfect resolution but I'll take it you
know it's a baby steps for his
rebuilding whatever that pageant
friendship was I still don't know what
went wrong there I still want to know
but I'm glad Caitlin went Anna and said
let's just talk about it instead of you
talking about it in front of a group of
people and not just directly to me but
it's hard enough as women and hard
enough as as we've both been through
such tough things so I think my thing is
why not be supportive of one another
then we have a situation just like
Hannah and Kaylin last week we're now
Demi and Courtney are going to Colton
about each other and this just never
goes well it's never a good idea and you
know it and I didn't want Demi to go
here I didn't want dummy to do this
because I'd agreed with her on the
Courtney thing up until this point but
then she calls Courtney cancer I mean
doesn't help you to throw that word
around who did you agree with here Demi
or Courtney because I will say Courtney
was doing something that really
frustrates me she I felt was I thought
she had attacked Demi she'd critiqued
her called her mature all these things
that she kept arguing that she was doing
it with a calm voice just because you're
saying mean things to someone in a calm
voice doesn't mean you're not saying
mean things to them so at the end of the
day I still sided with Debbie on this
one I felt Courtney did seem to be
spreading a lot of negativity but what
did you guys think if Debbie had aside
that cancer thing
or some side with her
going into this rose ceremony there is
just so much tension so we get to the
rose ceremony and I wrote down oh my god
Demi is holding her the rose in her
teeth I'm dying
Debbie's giving us a lot of good face
during these Rose ceremonies guys like
she's taking every opportunity on camera
and I really applaud her for it
a tough rose ceremony to predict I
actually wrote down my predictions I
said I'm gonna predict kirpa and then
whoever the woman is I don't know her
name who gave Colton a set of chopsticks
and also Tracy because I just felt like
we haven't seen them a lot this episode
those three and Tracy's time I felt had
been coming since last episode right and
then oh I'm wrong kirpa is still around
okay uh interesting
the seasons giving us a lot of surprises
isn't it like last week I was the
surprise of Brienne captain went home
and I'm surprised kirpa stayed and then
oh my god I wrote again chopsticks girl
is still here I still don't know her
name
Oh turns out her name is Katie I did
write that down I also scribbled
important notes such as ooh I like
Elise's dress at the end of the day good
bye to Tracy I did call that one and
goodbye to Courtney uncle anyway
whatever Debbie's doing guys props her
because her two foes Tracy and Courtney
are no mo goodbye and Demi is living
large and in charge she made the mistake
of with me and
now she's out the door she even made the
toast at the end of the rose ceremony
and said goodbye to the leeches can no
more freaking leeches ever again I think
she was talking about Tracy and Courtney
on the patch
and then we get the trailer for next
week and Heather might get her first
kiss and Colton and Cassie have their
own Island to do whatever with though I
don't think there's much to do on that
Island because it just appears to be a
pile of sand and it does at least do
something messy it certainly seems to
indicate that oh my god good the woman
we thought was perfect Elise go down a
dark path some people are already
calling for to be the Bachelorette but
we haven't seen the rest of this season
we don't know all of the story sometimes
people are icy cold and sometimes
there's more to things than meets the
eye and sometimes you eat a fish I
that's it everybody and thank you as
always for your love and support and I'm
here to answer your questions and your
comments and you know what I don't know
how to end this so let's just bring JC
and to say something lovely to give us a
thought on love and by the way JC and I
dressed the same way but not on purpose
work we're becoming the same person it's
fine
so babe was just like a lovely thought
on love that we can add on today mm-hmm
you know love is sometimes a dress in
two pair of shoes
she's an Internet or burger and fries
did not think you were gonna say that
but I'll take it we love a burger and
fries and by the way guys we love your
thoughts we love hearing from you want
to know what you think of the season of
The Bachelor
again ratings are up it's doing very
well this season better than last year
rightfully so we are loving it we love
Colton we love each other we love you
okay let us know by E yeah you know when
you're doing an iPhone video you should
kind of what's good as we keep really
shaky cuz like really they're kind of
natural and sort of like really vlogger
and natural looking so you know how's it
gonna be fine
[Music]